good afternoon everybody welcome to the
Macmillan Center I mean Shapiro who
currently the
to hear I'm just delighted to be able to
host Peter heart as the speaker for the
coca-cola world fund lecture at Yale
this lecture was established in 1992 by
the late Roberto boy sweater who is the
founder and chair and CEO of the
coca-cola company and in 1953 graduate
of Yale College the Macmillan Center
sponsors this event along with the law
school and the school of management but
before getting to the lecture I would
like to introduce a very special guest
that we have joining us this in this
afternoon Clyde Tuggle is the senior
vice president and chief public if chief
public affairs and communications
officer at the coca-cola company we're
pleased to have him here with us today
and I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank Clyde and the coca-cola company
for their generous support and active
involvement in so many of the programs
here at Yale so please welcome mr. Clyde
Tuggle thank you thank you ian and good
afternoon and welcome to this annual
coca-cola world fun Yale lecture now I'm
going to ask you some questions and I
want you to think carefully about your
answers imagine there's a movie called
the life of Mitt Romney what actor would
you get to play him and why if you were
a fly on the wall in what situation
would you like to observe President
Obama if there was only one seat left on
a plane and Newt Gingrich was fifth in
line how would he make certain he got
that seat what would he do and this is
my favorite if you could play dr.
Frankenstein and take all of the best
elements from each of the presidential
candidates what elements would you take
from each person the funny thing is that
these are all actual questions used by
today's distinguished lecturer
though I did take the liberty of filling
in the candidates names Peter these
questions odd as they are demonstrate
the kind of innovative thinking and
offbeat creativity it takes to build a
reputation as the preeminent pollster in
America today for more than 40 years our
speaker is specialized in taking the
pulse of the public in good times and
bad times and all the in-between times
during his career he represented more
than 40 US senators and 30 governors
along with first the late Robert Teeter
and now bill McInturff he has been the
pollster of NBC News in the wall street
journal since 1989 he has worked
internationally in South America Europe
Asia and Africa and he has conducted
research for companies including IBM IBM
AT&T and in the interest of full
disclosure the coca-cola company he's
frequently featured on television
appearing on such programs as Meet the
Press and The Today Show at the moment
the truth be told he's more interested
in watching TV than appearing on it and
i'm referring not to the imminent return
of mad men but to the March Madness of
college basketball he has a unique way
of looking at the NCAA tournament given
the many schools with which he's
affiliated he's a proud alumnus of Colby
College but the nest CAC Division three
white mules didn't quite qualify this
year he teaches at the University of
Pennsylvania's Annenberg School of
Communication but the fighting Quakers
haven't been to the Big Dance since 2007
he also teaches at UC Berkeley but the
Cal Bears lost in the first round and
while he has also taught at Duke he did
not pick this number two seed even to
reach the Final Four instead yes his big
bet on Ohio State to claim the
championship perhaps inspired in this
election year by the enduring political
axiom as Ohio goes so goes the nation
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming the chairman of Peter dehart
research associates mr. Peter heart
Thank You Clyde and thank you all very
very much I'm delighted to be here I'm
honored Ian thank you very much for
having me and this is a special lecture
and indeed a special opportunity and I
do profess that I do have an unusual way
of choosing my teams for the for the
final four and this year out of 109
entries after the first week I'm in
third place so I'm feeling very robust
but by tonight Caitlin I'm going to be
way down in the pool but right now I'm
okay in any respect I have to tell you I
I recognize and Ian particularly honored
to be at the etch-a-sketch a special
lecture series anything that I say today
will be good for the next 24 hours and
then we'll see where it goes Clyde was
kind enough I have to say to to
introduce me without the usual thing
that happens every introduction Clyde I
have to tell you and that is I'm always
introduced as a veteran pollster and you
know what that means because people come
up afterwards and they say what was it
like pulling for James Polk was Garfield
that much fun and a true story happened
to me in the University of California at
Berkeley it was in the it was in my
first class in 2009 and a student came
running up to me at the end of the class
and she she says professor you have to
tell me what was the most exciting
election you've ever been in was it
Obama's what's a Kennedy or was it
Roosevelt
Roosevelt I wasn't even alive for
Roosevelt and she says no no no no i
meant franklin not teddy so you know I
know what it's like and you know the
other thing i have to tell you is it's
great to be here in New Haven because
here there's an appreciation for so many
things that you do and the way in which
academic credentials is established you
I come from a town which is Washington
DC and in Washington DC you know we're a
town about power that's all it is and do
what it's all about and you may not know
this story but there's a pocketable
story I'm sure about secretary of state
hillary clinton she was giving one of
these fancy lectures and she said the
Dyess big dinner tables all throughout
the ball rope and the waiter comes up
and and puts a pat of butter on
Hillary's plate and she said excuse me I
have a second pad of butter and the
waiter says sorry one pat per person
hello princess well maybe you don't know
who i am who i just says no i don't she
says look I'm Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton part of that I ran for president
the United States got 17 million votes
almost made it prior to that senator
from New York prior to that I was first
lady of the land on the way to turn to
her and said well maybe you don't know
who i am and Heller said no and she said
and he says I'm the man in charge of the
butter and and that's the way it goes in
Washington power and power is fleeting
powers forever changing and indeed what
I thought I'd do is talk a little bit
about where we are today and what's
happening and I hate to do it but I i
want to start if I can by getting
everybody just stand up because I want
to see
I'm going to see is this a new age crowd
or an old age I thought if I in it I've
got four questions and yes you have to
sit down now my prediction here is fewer
than six will be standing okay here we
go first question do you wear a
wristwatch if the answer is yes okay
next do you have a landline phone at
home no landline phone amazing okay
number three do you read a printed
newspaper your what no no a printed
newspaper okay what once a week okay
okay we're we're now we're now at 5 45
okay last question do you use your cell
phone more as to use cell rather than to
text so if you use it more as a cell
phone you sit down we end up with 0 it
is a new age crowd interestingly enough
if you go into any classroom over half
your students would be standing up and
essentially well you're the other half
yeah that's probably why you're indoors
today in any respect I my monitor here
in any respect what I thought is this is
just a way to talk about where we're
where we are and how things have changed
and what I thought I'd do is talk about
L we ate six elements about
understanding the country on what is
half
I mean at this stage of the game first
thing to understand is the direction of
the country where are we in terms of
America essentially only about thirty
percent of Americans thirty-three
percent say things are headed in the
right track over sixty percent say
things are seriously off on the wrong
track and you look at this and that
becomes terribly important as a
barometer for where this country is
going and the challenge ahead of Barack
Obama indeed I would tell you if the
numbers under thirty percent there's a
good chance the president will not be
reelected if the number is over forty
percent there's a very good chance he
will be reelected we've gone through
almost a decade with the exception of a
few spikes like after Osama bin Laden
was killed in which in which the country
has never been fifty percent saying
things are headed in the right direction
longest period of time we know second
thing is the optimism in the economy
that's improving I'll talk about it more
but it is still negative people still
think there is a there is a long way to
go to get back to where we've been the
third thing is trust in every
institution has just dropped out of
sight you can look at the financial
institutions at the bottom of the list
but you can take almost every other
institution one way or another and you
can see that things have indeed become
exceptionally negative the fourth
element in terms of all of this is
America's place in the world we asked a
question for NBC in the wall street
journal about 15 years ago which country
do you think a generation from now will
be the tsongas economic power in the
world by a margin of fifty-four percent
to two percent they said the United
States turn two percent say China isn't
quite a few people said the EU or Japan
today about forty percent say the United
States about forty percent say China
again the sense of insecurity of where
we are and what's happening the fifth
thing is how many people here in this
audience who have had a a better
standard a better life than their
parents
okay most as you look around most
everybody how many think your children
will have a better standard of life than
you do hands up okay they've got the
trust funds go after these people in any
respect the only thing I can say is
that's exactly what we find for 13
generations we have handed the we've
handed the baton forward to the next
generation today what we find is we
believe that we're gonna hand the baton
backwards and the last thing is the
American public for the first time
doesn't believe that we're in one of
these little down troughs but it is the
beginning of a state of decline so that
captures what the 2012 election is about
it is this period of great insecurity a
changing time a time when Americans are
not only trying to figure out how to get
out of the recession but a sense that
greater waves are coming over us much
greater problems are ahead of us and so
for those of you in the audience that
seem positive and feel comfortable that
Barack Obama will be reelected I tell
you be careful because these are the
macro forces and the macro forces shape
an election if you look we're really in
a transformational era and when I talk
about this the power shift that is going
on and we can go back in time but if you
look and you go to the Arab Spring and
you move forward all of the changes that
have happened and all the things that
have happened this is moving from from
nation state to communities to
individuals and you can see it more and
more and more second thing is winning
and losing is magnified you can be at
the top of the heap and move to the
bottom of the heap so very very quickly
give me an example of a of a company or
an individual that you admired that
you've lost you've lost faith in
recently anybody this is a participial
Kodak ok good why codec
good who else anybody else how about
Goldman Sachs oh yeah all good old
Goldman Sachs I mean at the top of the
heap how about anybody know Sean Payton
who's he New Orleans New Orleans Saints
coach is the next year nope they've
banned him one day at the top now at the
bottom how about somebody going from the
bottom to the top Jeremy Lin thank you
very much high five for you Jeremy Lin
Tim Tebow etc all I'm saying is the
magnification in which things change at
this stage acceleration is unbelievable
third thing is your competition will
come from the most unlikely sources I
mean if if you are a international
university how many how many campuses do
you now have outside the United States
in China Yale yep and and what it tells
you is that again the way in which
things are happening though why some
posts are struggling newspaper biggest
competition where's that all their ad
revenue going Craigslist why because
there's no more a if I want to be able
to get something or sell something it's
much quicker and easier on craigslist
and i don't need the newspaper and so it
is for everybody else and the last is
the worst position to be is in the
biggest best first and most and the
quickness then which we go from being a
general motors at the top to the bottom
is takes no time AIG you can go through
them all but all of this is changing and
all of this is part of the new world
that we're in the other thing that you
can say is that we've gone from a
symmetrical world to an asymmetrical
world in our symmetrical world just the
world I grew up in back with James Polk
but you stop and think about the
symmetric
world that we grew up in you know I you
either watchcon cater you watch huntley
brinkley you were either a coke family
or a Pepsi family you were either a GM
car or you were a Ford car family you
either you read the morning newspaper
the evening newspaper all of those
things you were Russia or capitalism and
communism all of these things existed
and essentially it was a very
interesting bifurcated a kind of market
today we are now in an asymmetrical
world where things are moved by
absolutely individuals in a way of going
you stop and think about it's the
internet that got a fortiori ruler out
of power it was the internet and
individuals i mentioned washington post
in craigslist you know you stop and
think about your parents or your
generations and we used to fight wars
and wars were something where you
captured a river of battle as something
that there was a yo Jima if there was
d-day there was marne there was things
tell me tell me the one of the great
battles of tell me one of the great
battles of Iraq we've been there for ten
years can you name a battle can you name
something no because we no longer fight
armies we fight individuals and it's
individuals that change and tear down
things and everything else and again and
the last thing I like to think about is
if you look at Rick Santorum and Newt
Gingrich if i said to you a year ago
these two guys are going to be the
biggest competitors in the republican
primary you say they can't be there are
one-man bands they've got nothing
they're doing nothing there just out
there such as sole individuals but the
answer is you look and there they are a
competing against the big orchestras of
a Barack Obama and Mitt Romney all of
this is a way of saying look I thought
we were going to come here and talk
about politics and talked about 2012 you
can't talk about 2012 unless you step
back and look at the landscape and
recognize that the world in which will
be choosing this next president is so
different and so important I've talked
about the confidence and institutions it
just underscores how it's all changed
but I'll talk about one other thing
that's happened and that is the way in
which we look at at the commercial world
it is really fascinating and what we've
done is we've switched and what it is we
look at we look at brands we look at
companies as either predators or
partners and you stop and think if you
take the idea of the bank of america say
we're going to charge you five dollars a
month for your money to be able to have
it and come back you say that's an
outrage they're a predator they're
taking advantage when airline says oh
you're going to check a suitcase that
what you're going to do well I guess
what we're going to charge you money to
do that and the next thing is netflix
says oh I know we've had a relationship
but we're changing that relationship and
our new relationship guess what it's
going to be this relationship is going
to be based upon how you rent your
movies and so suddenly they change their
thing or you look at BP and how they
follow the environment or the verizon
then they're two-dollar convenience fees
all of those are predators but there are
other people who get it and they are
people who become your partner's sapos
who's uses a PO synthesis audience tell
me about zappos why you use it good you
use a pose why how many days how many
days 365 days ok that's a partner they
understand their fighting your fights
they're on your side they're doing what
you want you look at target target ends
up as an ally because they're involved
in the community they there's a sense of
an outreach there's a sense that they
understand both fashion and pricing
jcpenney anybody see the ellen degeneres
ads
brilliant brilliant ads why Marilyn you
no longer need to receipt so very
cleverly what they've said is we're not
going to hold you up we're going to
believe you we're going to trust you in
other words they've made the bridge
across and you can look at Southwest
where your bags fly free and you don't
have to pay for choice all of this so
you look at this and you say well Jesus
is in politics it is politics because
what the American public's trying to
figure out is who's going to be their
partners and who are the Predators who's
on their site and who's on the other
side so I take all of this and this is
where we end up a rebellion in America
Wall Street occupy wall street was that
an accident is that something that
disappeared because winters over or was
a harsh winter or whatever else it is we
had a question in our NBC poll and we
simply said the American public do you
agree or disagree with the following
statement that the current economic
structure of the country is out of
balance and favors a very small
proportion of the rich over the rest of
the country America needs to reduce the
power of major banks and corporation and
demand greater accountability and
transparency etc and if you look at that
you have seventy-six percent of
Americans sixty percent strongly agree
with that statement and you look at even
Republicans you get sixty one percent of
them in agreement twenty-three percent
of Americans on our most recent NBC Wall
Street Journal poll said I am a member
of Occupy Wall Street and there's twenty
five percent twenty four percent of
Americans who say I'm a member of the
tea party or supportive the tea party
that's forty seven percent of americans
say I'm either in one camp or the other
camp and I think it underscores sort of
where we're at and what is happening and
it is the sense that how do we get
consensus in this kind of world and it
is the sense that I look ahead and I say
what are the possibilities of change and
I see a lot of change that is happening
and one of the things I think at least
you to the idea that they're very
maybe a third party candidate or a third
candidate that comes into this race now
if you look at this at the bottom of the
chart is the Congress everything that
we've done everything everybody else has
done has shown exactly where the
Congress is its job rating is twenty
percent and has not been a majority in
over a decade people rate this is one of
the worst Congress you end up with half
the people say I want to get a new
person rather than reelect all of those
things are telling how unhappy people
are and how disappointed they are with
the way things are going that sets up
the election and what you find is both
parties are indeed and lows they
Republican which is a fascinating thing
you look at the Republican Party over
the course since they've taken over
their negative has risen their positive
has dropped and essentially they're now
at a period of time where forty-three
percent have negative feelings and
thirty-two percent have positive
feelings and you look at this and I'll
tell you something in the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll for the years 1989
to 2005 we never did one single survey
where there were as many people aware
there were people both negative towards
the Republicans and the Democrats over
the last six years we've had half of our
surf way where voters are negative
towards both parties that gives you a
sense of where things are at and you
wonder why you look for the Republican
Party it's been the leadership in
Congress as one of my friend says you
look at you look at Mitch McConnell and
he has everything but the charisma of
harry reid and and you look at the
republican party sort of straight out
from Susan G Komen through rush limbaugh
all of those things have had a
tremendous effect it's not only on the
inside it's on the outside and if
somebody said that
on newt gingrich error newt gingrich the
rush limbaugh's now down to two sponsors
on his new show one is Crisco and the
other is Twinkies ah but he still has
some for the Democratic Party it's been
rough times too it's now slightly more
positive than negative but only slightly
more positive you look at this and I
think there are five keys to
understanding the 2012 election the
first thing is everybody says the most
important things to understand is who's
ahead no it isn't it's the least
important don't pay any attention to
that number that number changes hour to
hour it means nothing watch the dynamics
don't look and say oh my goodness
Romney's ahead by two points or Obama's
ahead by three points those are not the
things that count those are not central
second thing is watch the president's
reelect number we'll talk about this a
little bit when the president gets over
fifty percent and reelect number he's in
good shape when it's in the forty five
percent unless he's in trouble we find
them somewhere in between that it is a
marginal number at this stage of the
game number three this election like
every election is going to be decided by
the middle and when I think about the
middle I think about the suburbs I think
about independence I think about I think
about the Midwest I on I think about
white collar workers you look at those
groups and you watch and see if the
vectors are all point in one direction
or another and you have a pretty good
sense of where things are at the next
thing is enthusiasm and turn out I'll
talk about this in a moment but let me
explain the reason that Barack Obama one
and one so comfortably in 2008 was turn
out that in states like North Carolina
and states like Virginia even in Indiana
definitely in in Colorado and New Mexico
and Nevada the turnout favorite the
Democrats that is a number to watch it
has been favoring the Republicans in
2011 by a wide margin it's not the case
today
and finally expect the unexpected
anybody want give me an unexpected for
2012 who's got one Iran okay a foreign
policy event can change this election I
agree what else but a bank default
absolutely if suddenly the bank's come
crashing down or something economically
related anybody else who I think that's
an interesting thing again expecting the
unexpected good answer and I would say a
third party candidate changes all of
those things we say at this stage of the
game well we're we're in the middle of
March you know not that much it's going
to happen the answer is a tongue is
going to happen if you stop and think of
all the things that have happened over
the last two hundred and twenty days
think about the 220 dates ahead it's not
going to be less it's going to be more
so that's what I'm telling you and in
the end of the day it comes around to
what James Carville said it's the
economy stupid and you look and the
thing that I found the single most
helpful number to look at is one that
was established by the university of
michigan consumer confidence index and
they started this actually back in 1956
if you follow this this tells you where
the heads of the american public so is
at in terms of thinking about how much
confidence you have in the economy and
we've been measuring this and we've had
four recession's over the past over the
past 50 years this is the worst
recession we have ever had the longest
before this was 46 months and it went
from 1973 in nineteen seventy nine to
nineteen eighty-three any time there is
a recession incumbent presidents have
been thrown out of office so you can
look at the recession of or the
incumbent party you can look at
obviously 1975 and Ford went out in 70
is 76 obviously ad with Carter boy
41 and and then obviously through a
recession that that Bush 43 and if this
number goes up to 85 that means we're
out of the recession the number is
obviously climbed from a low it would
last August during the budget impasse
but we're still a long way from 85 that
is a important number to watch and it
will give you a clue as to whether we're
getting out of this or not if you look
at this election this is our last NBC
Wall Street Journal poll came out last
week or two weeks ago now and we have
Barack Obama ahead of Mitt Romney by
fifty two forty four percent somebody
would say well that's a pretty good
comfortable figure how many by the way
here say the next president in the
United States will be Barack Obama hands
up okay this is how I get paid because i
say i took a cross-section of americans
and it's a cheap cheap way to do this
how many people say that mitt romney
will be the next president of the united
states we got not a bad bet in any
respect what you look at is not only the
totals and remember this an important
thing that we're at a period where mitt
romney has gone through tough times and
obama's had a lot of good things
happening and this is the best numbers
we've had for him in over two years so
you look at this he he leads with women
by 18 points huge turnaround with women
because of the way in which the
republicans have had handled the
contraception question and and the
healthcare questions etc the midwest
where the president did very well he is
ahead by 10 points in dependencies ahead
by seven points all of those are good
signs but then take a look at the
suburbs at this stage the game we have
romney ahead barack obama won that in 08
by a narrow margin the interesting thing
is suburban women suburban women were
we're going the other way in the fall
they have turned around in the
Congressional pairing work that we've
done the Republicans had a nine-point
advantage they now have a nine-point
deficit with suburban women that's the
price of the whole contraception
argument and finally the president has
always been strong with young people
what we found most encouraging here is
that with voters over 65 for the first
time he is actually back to parody or
dead even you look at this race
obviously it has a long way to go but at
this stage of the game the president has
gone from a position of being an
underdog to at least being equal in his
position here the assets that the
president has going for him and here are
the liabilities you look the most
important asset that he has is in every
piece of work that we've been able to do
about forty four percent of the voters
say that they indeed they indeed are
with him he has a very very solid base
and I can't tell you how exceptionally
important that is as a way in which to
build from so he's their second thing as
they personally like them Clyde kids me
because I asked a lot of different
question but when the questions I love
to ask I'll ask it here let's suppose
that Barack Obama were your next-door
neighbor what would he be like what
Barack well I'm gonna be like his your
next door neighbor friendly and helpful
consider it how about him okay who else
you'd watch a game with a probably
basketball okay what else anybody else
private okay so not that outgoing
anybody else informed yep anybody else
intelligent how about how about his
family warm yeah it's a good father yeah
and how about what's his dog's name oh
okay all
those elements okay what Oh Michelle
yeah yeah dynamite I agree we love
Michelle okay now let's turn it around
your next-door neighbors Newt Gingrich
tell me about your next-door neighbor
what if what and what you're moving yeah
uh and and how about Calista warm and
cuddly Oh God okay uh and how about Mitt
Romney what would he be like his your
next-door neighbor called what nice wife
okay good what about him changing
calculating uh you know what people tell
me about him high hedges okay but all of
this counts and makes a difference and
so you look at that and foreign policy
the president was supposed to come in
and not be strong on foreign policy we
remember the 3am ad well the fact of the
matter is he's been dynamite on foreign
policy in part because he's had a great
Secretary of State he's had two great
secretaries of defense and he has been
rock solid in terms of that and the
public appreciates he has all of these
qualities over romney this is older data
but still it gives you a sense he's got
problems the economy is still in trouble
they're not happy they don't agree with
them with on all the policies health
care is still a major sell he hasn't
done a good job there and finally the
his reelect score it's fine but not but
not great so that's sort of where the
race stands now to me the most
interesting thing and this is the data
that we just finished is Mitt Romney's
been winning the primaries and I think
the analysts have been covering these
primaries all wrong and the reason I say
that is because when when Mitt Romney
wins
michigan by three points they say one he
won he's got momentum he's winning Ohio
etc and the problem is what it is really
can he consolidate the Republican Party
we asked a simple question of people who
were non Romney voters we said to him if
he becomes the nominee is he acceptable
to you or not acceptable and essentially
what we find out and by the way that
group makes up sixty-two percent of all
Republicans ah thirty-seven percent say
he's unacceptable to me and that's a
huge block of voters so what we not
picking up here is not the fact that
he's winning but look at the difference
between people who didn't vote for him
who think he's acceptable and people who
don't feelings towards him 55 29 among
those who say they acceptable among that
other group fifty-five percent negative
yes that's that's a great question and
what is fascinating about this one I
didn't ask that exact question but I
looked at Hillary voters on Obama
Hillary voters did not hate Obama they
loved Hillary but they didn't hate Obama
it was a pitch fight but it was a pitch
fight on the positive side of things
where the loyalties were really very
very positive and so when at the end of
the race while Obama still had some
consolidating to do it was a much easier
consolidation this situation is really
and go run down the figures look at this
shares my position on the issues if
you'd ask Hillary voters about Obama it
would have been overwhelming positive
but among this group it's 72 65 cares
about the average person 12 261 a
reliable conservative 72 68 and that's
why that Etch A Sketch remark was such a
killer yesterday because it reinforced
what everybody believes which is this
guy is going to change and he's going to
change change on a dime in fact my
friend mark she
Elle's told me a little story yesterday
he said that a liberal a moderate and
conservative all walk into a bar sit
down at the bar stool and the bartender
said what will you have Mitt Romney and
that's the problem you don't know who
he's going to be from day to day and
that's the difficulty that the public is
having with them and that's why the
etch-a-sketch so you look at this and
you say every Democrat deserves a gift
and if it would happen to be either
Santorum or Gingrich you get a sense of
how bad things could be for the
Republicans among women muchas happens
to lose those just by a by a close 27
points and if you look Santorum with as
one marriage is still losing them by 24
points you look in terms of independence
the margin is 25 and 21 if anybody but
Romney were the nominee coming from
these wings of the party they would have
a huge problem so it's not as though
Romney is beating goliaths he's beating
Lilliputians and so he's barely getting
through that he's getting through that
on sort of a week-by-week basis out of
all of this our personalities I've got
three of them up here and they glide
mentions that I like to ask a lot of
offbeat questions I do so for a
particular reason I honestly believe the
presidential vote is the most personal
vote that we make in our lives and the
reason it's the most personal is because
obviously the importance of the stakes
but I also think that this is a person
who is in your living room dining room
kitchen bedroom 200 days a year
and so we think of them in very
different terms and it's a very much
vote from the gut and I decided to come
up with a question that I asked a couple
months ago and I said give me some types
of people that are in your 5th grade go
back to when you were in the fifth grade
give me a type of person who was in your
5th grade class don't give me a name
give me a type of person class bully who
else has got one class clown like it the
oddball who else shy kid who else we're
learning about each person's personality
yes okay what else prankster what else
teacher's pet good what else what else
we got nerd good who else leader good
what else does a good list of people so
what we did is we gave them different a
different terms nerd respected
all-american loner rich privileged kid
hard worker know-it-all star athletes
teacher's pet bullied and I said to him
right down for each of the candidates
who they were so who was Newt Gingrich
okay bully know-it-all Anna nerd that's
exactly what the people said that's who
he comes across as okay how about Mitt
Romney there's a surprise hey anybody
got a couple Cadillacs here in any
respect that's that and who is ron paul
he they couldn't figure out they thought
he was the kid with the chemistry said
who would probably blow up the class and
you say to me why was Santorum not
included he was home-schooled
so so we didn't include them but but the
important point that you emerge from all
of this is that in terms of personality
it is the way in which they can connect
to not connect and at this stage of the
game the problem challenge challenge for
Mitt Romney is he doesn't have quote the
common touch yeah who was the one who
said how about his wife I like Ann
Romney yeah as a great point she comes
across well she's friendly she's
down-to-earth she's warm she has a
disability and yet there is all that
humaneness in her every time that Mick
goes off the script he's dead and so the
question is will he find that way of
connecting in this race I you look back
and I can remember in two thousand I ask
a question in one of my focus groups let
us suppose that your job has been
transferred and it's going to be an hour
commute and the only way you can shorten
the hour commute is the hov lanes and
you have a choice you have to either
have al gore george w bush as your
companion in the car for the next 30
days well nobody chose al gore because
they said I'd be I'd be put to sleep it
would be boring it would be terrible i
can live with george w bush and in the
end there was a lot of that and and the
fact of the matter is for Mitt Romney
the big challenge is how do you connect
how do you make it work and that's
indeed it so you look at this and I just
want to say the election is a long long
way off and let me just stop and have
you think about it if you think we're
229 days from the election in 2012 turn
the clock back 229 days Arnold Arnold
Schwarzenegger's wife didn't know that
he has she had another place to set at
the table
you look Kim Kardashian didn't even know
she was getting married let alone being
divorced 229 days ago we didn't know
about Herman Cain or his private life
229 days ago we didn't know that moammar
qaddafi would be deposed and killed and
we didn't know about Wall Street Occupy
Wall Street that's how far the election
is from today we look at these things we
say it's ancient history and what I'm
telling you is we have so much of a road
to go and as you look at this election
and think about this election it is so
important to recognize it is the basics
that are going to drive this election
and while we can laugh about H's sketch
by the time we get to october there will
be a thousand other things that will
happen both up and down so that's the
way i see it and i'll be delighted to
take questions thank you very much ok
questions yes
where do you see a third-party candidate
coming from well I would have said at
the beginning of the race it's
definitely coming from the right I just
believe that it is the people that are
unhappy with Romney that will add that
will look that way I would have thought
it's ron paul i feel a little less
positive at this moment but i think that
it will come there is a vehicle that's
set up that is and that is aimed at
putting somebody on every ballot in
which would be an internet vote Tom
Friedman's talked about this Americans
elect and essentially it's aimed at
being bipartisan it could be taken over
by any of the parties depending upon how
they want to do it i would say
candidates from any wing i think that
that's another possibility any third
party i think hurts hurts the Challenger
the president has the strongest base I
don't think his base will change much
what we've seen is even if it's a
Michael Bloomberg who we tested and he
got thirteen percent and ron paul got 18
the vote was much more likely to come
from the middle and the right and come
out of the republican hide question here
do you think the country is as divided
as Congress's and it's a bipartisan or
partisan as Congress's uh the country is
definitely partisan and it is polarized
so don't want to suggest that they're
not but I think what they are looking
for is a sense of compromise the ability
for us to be able to find a way to reach
common ground I did they may be divided
but there are so many areas where they
say I mean when you look at something
like simpson-bowles it was a tragedy I
beyond a tragedy that the American
public did not insist on that going
through when you look at the at the
divided from the budget debate last
summer it was a tragedy that the
difference was 200 billion dollars or
whatever the number was and the public
just lost all confidence so from the
point of view that the Republicans and
the Democrats tend to be intransigent
when it comes to acting but the public
is definitely partisan and definitely
divided they just don't necessarily want
intransigence okay what is your opinion
on on the Tea Party are they going to
lose and and the likelihood for the
Democrats to keep the Senate or their I
dream to get back the house um well
again it's a very very difficult
election looking ahead in terms of in
terms of the House of Representatives
the biggest challenge facing the
Democrats is are there enough seats open
and at this stage of the game I don't
think there are for the Democrats to
take over though I do believe that the
Republican Party has hurt their brand
tremendously in terms of the United
States Senate if I'd been here a year
ago I would have said the Republicans
are favored at this stage not only
because of olympia snowe but also
because of various democratic candidates
that have gotten in the chances are much
better so you look at Connecticut your
own state the chances of holding on for
a Democrat are better than I would have
thought they would be
I think you look at new mexico that's
another state where we had a retirement
there's a possibility there North Dakota
is a long shot but there are enough
places and they're impossible pick up
with Elizabeth Warren in Massachusetts
Nevada is another possible pick up so I
think the Democrats will hold on in the
Senate the key is the states of Virginia
and Ohio which again depending on
turnout it will make a difference the
one thing I did not speak about here is
enthusiasm at last year the Republicans
had a nine-point enthusiasm advantage at
this stage it's down to two so that's
been the price that the Republicans have
paid for their for their fight in the
party yep next I had a question about
how we factor in disfranchisement here
and the kind of systematic
disfranchisement that's going on and you
talked about how romney is unable
individually to consolidate the party
but there is a machine operation
essentially happening behind him
nationally to disfranchise the very
people who were able to come out and
vote for obama and so you know i mean
yeah the suburbs has been important in a
national calculation since say the late
60s or the 70s but what happened in 2008
in places like Virginia in North
Carolina was you got the rural people
out to vote you got african-americans
out to vote or in cities like Bridgeport
Chicago you you know you were able to
really get out an african-american vote
and other people had a Hispanic vote so
how do you put systematic
disfranchisement in there as a factor
that actually tips the tips the balance
of power it's an excellent excellent
question if there are two things that
have me more upset than anything else
about the American political system one
is the element of trying to
disenfranchise people through the
identification card efforts that the
Republic
have pushed it is nothing more than
disenfranchisement it is it has no other
objective besides that it is important
and makes a difference even more
important than that is the Citizens
United decision that has taken the
election out of the hands of the
American public and the candidates and
have given it to the surrogates who now
become the candidate and the candidate
is free of as absolved of anything that
goes on this will be on both sides of
the aisle but it is a terrible thing
both of those are terribly important I
worry about the disenfranchisement I
don't think it's going to be as large as
we thought it could have become but
it'll be there more importantly it will
people care enough particularly
Democrats everything that we see within
the african-american community suggests
that their interest level is still
exceptionally high and they recognize
the state as stakes and I expect them to
run and to be there next question paul
ryan's budget two point oh just released
how is that polling there any data on
that yet and how do you think we can go
forward with the state of uncompromised
to fixing our budget problems the second
question have no idea how we're going to
go forward and we're going to make this
work I assume we will continue into
serves this state of not dealing with
the budget I only know a little bit
about budgeting but the only thing I can
say is that when you're going to reduce
the marginal rate of everybody you're
going to take in less money the only
places that you can take money from are
the things that are the most critical to
the American public and I can't imagine
this is a winning budget once it gets
discussed I think this will be something
that the Republicans you notice that
Romney did not rush out and endorsed it
I think this will be something that the
Republicans will drift away from I
imagine that they will embrace that and
that will be in part of of their plan I
think it's too open to attack if you're
going to gut all of the central programs
that the public counts on so my guess is
that it's not going to work but that's
my perception and we haven't pulled on
it yet you know what interests me is
that in the last several months there
have been two events that have been very
much affected by social networking in
the internet the that I remember the
bank of america situation and this
recent situation with this teenager in
Florida yeah and I'm just wondering if
you see this as a trend and how it might
affect number one our whole society but
number two our election and will it also
affect anything to regarding the MV the
party conventions I that's the reason I
started out where I did was which is the
trend towards asymmetry in America and
that is the whole social network in the
way in which we've changed it's also the
reason had everybody stand up at the
beginning is a way of saying that we
live in an old world I I wear a watch I
ray i read a printed newspaper i I have
a landline phone and I text less than I
use my cell phone i'm part of i'm part
of the era that has gone by and in every
other way all of the things that are
happening whether it's on twitter or
whether it is on social networking it
changes the world and indeed it is so
central now the thing that happens with
this is change becomes accelerated and
magnified and so you can look and you
look at our polls it made no sense i
mean you had Rick Perry announced and
suddenly he was up at the top of the
heap ahead of everybody else nobody knew
anything about him but somehow he seemed
like he was different from the other and
then he couldn't remember what his third
agency was and an hour later we forgot
about him
we loved Herman Cain for an hour and a
half and then we found out about his
mistresses and then we said we hate him
and then we loved Santorum or Gingrich
for a little bit and that's that's one
of the problems how do you get a
leveling effect that happens but it is
absolutely central in terms of what's
happening and it is going to be that
much more important and the ability to
to react and and Clyde as you will
remember it was really a blogger in
India an individual blogger if I
remember correctly Oh California that
had a tremendous impact upon coca-cola
and by contrast newmont mining had a
environmental record that was a
disastrous covered by covered by
frontline on PBS and a four-page spread
in the new york times and didn't get a
ripple it is the way in which the world
is changing and what's going on there
yes what's the role of Hillary Clinton
in this election do you think she would
be a stronger Democratic ended than
Obama and the answer is you never
replace a sitting president certainly
one with fifty percent with with
somebody else obviously I think the
President Obama would be a stronger
candidate let me tell you I I saw
Secretary Clinton the other night nice
told her that one of the most gratifying
numbers that I've had in my last four
years was the fact that at the end of
last campaign forty percent of the
american public leichter and forty
percent of the american public disliked
her most polarizing individuals straight
through at this stage of the game you
have about fifty five percent of the
american public having positive feelings
twenty-five percent negative that is a
tremendous change and what i said is
it's not it's not only Republicans not
disliking her
it is the middle of the electorate
moving to like her she has done a
fantastic job as Secretary of State and
is amazingly popular i do i think that
the president would replace Joe Biden
with Hillary Clinton I don't think so i
think we've got the ticket and that will
be the ticket I one more question or do
we want a couple more okay good assuming
that romney is the candidate and selects
Jeb Bush as his running mate how
important with that selection babe I or
II heard of a from throughout the crowd
here yeah i was discussing facility on
the day with clyde and what i thought
was terribly important here is that Jeb
Bush signaled I think it's over I want
to align myself with Romney thus opening
up the possibility of that he brings two
things to the ticket number one Florida
terribly important or three things to
the ticket second thing is he brings the
bush machine it would be a tremendous
way to get all of those people involved
and it would help tremendously and the
third thing that he brings is he's the
most competent of the bush boys that's
not saying much but you know damned with
faint faint praise but indeed what it
comes down to is all three of those
things but the other thing that we've
learned and is exceptionally important
is that is that the American public is
not ready to go back and they don't want
another bush so I think it takes them
back to the past I think they want to
cut the past I think they want to run to
the future if I were looking towards the
vice presidency I think Mitt Romney has
a few ways to go number one would be to
go after a constituency so you choose a
candidate
who brings you a particular constituency
that could be the tea party right that
could be going after the Hispanic vote
with Marco Rubio from Florida also helps
you on a state but that could be one
element second element that you could do
is that you look at somebody who will
bring you a state Rob Portman from the
senator from Ohio played exceptionally
important role in bushes win in Ohio
down in Cincinnati area I think he has
both budget credentials having been a
CBO I or OMB thank you you get all these
numbers letters and he would be a
formidable there the third the third
element is you bring something that is a
character deficit so you're trying to
add in that way if I think Bush were to
do that I think he would look to chris
Christie chris Christie and style manner
and way I think in pitta Mieses a lot of
what the American public is looking for
somebody who's definitive who calls it
as he sees it who's excuse me speaks
from the gut and you know he's sort of
very much there so he can go any one of
those ways I don't think in the end he
goes towards a bush that would be my
guess it could he choose a woman that
would be going for a constituency it
would make sense the difficulty is if he
starts looking for a woman you know
you've you've eliminated olympia snowe
because obviously she's getting out you
can't go with a I don't think Susan
Collins would be acceptable to the Tea
Party and you can't go in that direction
and then you start looking at people
like Governor Martinez or
or nikki Haley down in South Carolina I
think they're just not ready for the
national stage if you've seen game
change I think if you tried an
unexperienced woman before you've done
that game so i would guess not for a
woman because there's not the perfect
candidate how many saw a game change by
the way okay I'll report it back Peter
assuming the president is re-elected
what do you think are the two or three
things that he will have to do in a
second term to leave office with a
sixty-five percent approval rating I two
or three things he would do nothing I
mean in other words I to be perfectly
honest anything that he's going to do
was going to take a lot of heavy lifting
and will not make more popular will make
him less popular I I must confess I was
a large supporter of President Obama in
the last election I thought that given
where the country was at and what we
needed to do he was an important answer
I don't think that He fulfilled
fulfilled the expectations at least that
I had above and the thing that I worry
about in a second term is not the
willingness to take on issues I'm just
not sure that he's going to be able to
strike the kind of political bargaining
that needs to be done in the Congress I
don't see unless we can get the budget
under control and getting us moving
forward on that front I don't know how
we move on all the other on all the
other fronts I mean they it's a changing
changing culture and I think the
American public we've asked the question
is if there were lever on the ballot
that kavod out every member of Congress
would you pull that lever fifty five
percent of the american public say
they'd pull that lever we want to start
over again and what we're trying to do
is to say we want our voice in here and
I think the American public feels very
squeezed out and and when I talk about
partner and predator partner and
predator really comes down to the end of
what we've been about
what we're talking about which is who's
going to listen to me and who's going to
fight my fights and at this stage of the
game the public looks at the Congress
and they look at citizens united and the
super PACs and all of that they say
nobody's fighting for me nobody's
listening to me that's why you have
Occupy Wall Street that's why you have a
tea party movement all of those things
count and to come back to your tea party
question I don't think that they fade
away but i think they continue to be a
force in in this in this election with
that I think we're ever so much I i have
to say i'm deeply indebted to Yale for
for having me I just appreciate ever so
much and to coca-cola and the memory of
mr. gazeta and Clyde it's a special
honor and I thank you all for allowing
me to be here